el juez Juan Carlos eccley evaluó las
más de 300 pruebas en base a testimonios
y de Testigos y documentos que aportó la
fiscalía para sustentar los delitos que
habría cometido el expresidente Pedro
castillo y es que para la justicia
peruana Pedro Castillo sería el líder de
una organización criminal y que habría
cometido diversos delitos se señala como
manipulación de una licitación en la
empresa Nacional de petróleos para la
compra de combustible también se le
acusa del delito de tráfico de
influencias por haber nombrado personas
allegadas a su entorno como funcionarios
públicos y a su vez articular la
manipulación de licitaciones y el cobro
de coimas en los ministerios de
transportes y de viviendas la fiscalía
tiene un caso sólido con pruebas contra
Pedro castillo y va a ser muy difícil
que sus abogados puedan defender al ex
gobernante el Ministerio Público también
señala que posee pruebas que Pedro
Castillo ha tenido una conducta
dilatoria durante las investigaciones y
que ha pretendido evadir la
responsabilidad en realidad las cosas
van de mal en peor en Pedro Castillo y
su entorno porque el Ministerio Público
también alista un pedido de prisión
preventiva contra la ex primer ministra
Betsy Chávez y por si esto no fuese
suficiente la justicia peruana ha
programado para el próximo 15 de junio
un pedido de prisión preventiva por 36
meses contra la ex primera dama Lilia
paredes esposa de Pedro Castillo